good evening good evening members and
welcome to this performance governance
and audit committee meeting on Thursday
the 9th of March 2023 my name is
councilor Wendy stamp and I will be
chairing this committee meeting members
we are streaming this meeting live as
well as recording and by being present
in the meeting you are given your
consent to being recorded during each
item please put your hand up to indicate
if you wish to speak I will then invite
you to at the appropriate time please
note that the YouTube live stream sound
recording is dependent on the correct
use of the microphones therefore can I
ask that when invited to speak you turn
on your microphone and turn it off when
finished members please please reference
a page and paragraph number when
referring to the agenda papers and keep
your contributions as clear and concise
as possible members can I remind you
that if you are later attending the
meter nobody's and we've got a full
house so thank you members I also
requested that officers attend PGA
meetings in person who are representing
and speaking on reports on all agenda
items in future meetings offices who
aren't present have the agreement of the
chairman to be remotely attending the
meeting don't know Mr Dodson
I also wish to remind members that at
the statutory annual meeting in November
2020 to enable member visibility it was
resolved that where papers are not
private and confidential and subject to
agreement by the relevant outside body
they would be stored on the Central
mod.gov Library for all members to
access
the appointment at the appointed member
Representatives is therefore asked to to
use the relevant fresh serve link to
submit papers
suggest you advise that the link will be
circulated oh sorry I they've suggested
I circulate the link but it's the fresh
serve link members
I'm guilty as many of the members for
not doing this in fact the only
counselor who has done this is our
excellent counselor who suddenly won't
be standing for election in May and
that's the vice chairman councilor
Stephen Nunn and we've had queries where
people can't access and don't know
what's going on outside working groups
and we have been advised which is what
that sentence what I've just read out is
um cancer Edwards
uh thank you chairman um
I'm on the Drapers from Sports Club
committee and when I attend the
committee meeting they discuss
Financial dealings the club makes on the
bar Etc so really confidential
information how do I get around that
um I would go through Mr Leslie I
certainly wouldn't put their financial
information if it's private and
confidential I I wouldn't do that you
can reject it yeah okay but check don't
just put it on there check check with
committee Services they'll they will
advise you or Mr Leslie thank you
um members I would like to welcome the
officers present in the chamber and the
officers operating remotely
um I won't go into that because I've
covered that with the Dodson
offices in attendance are Mr Dodson Mr
sorry oh sorry counselor Stevens thank
you chair sorry just going back to what
she was saying about
um lodging minutes I have tried to do
that because I knew that we needed to do
that and it failed and then an officer
told me you don't need to do that we do
that so there's something not quite
wholly right about that process
um Miss Casey can can I have Clarity on
that did you hear what cancer Stephen
says that she's tried to do it and an
officer has turned around and said she
doesn't need to do it or do you want me
to take that after the meeting
yes yes yes yes
information that would need to come from
the rec member representative but with
working groups obviously we manage the
national departments not community
services for civic support uploads all
the paperwork for working groups so I
think there just might be just some
confusion this always seems to be a
little bit of confusion between how the
working groups operate versus the
outside parties okay and if we would
expect members to upload the outside
body paperwork where appropriate uh
thank you Miss Casey um councilor um I
want to call you Emma Steve Stevens yeah
thank you yes that was my confusion
thank you okay all right so I would like
to welcome the officers Mr Dodson Mr
leslim Sue green is in the chamber
um and I think that's it and Mr Rubin
okay
um
officers remotely I'd like to also
welcome the Clark burner Casey Debbie
White is Debbie here yeah lead
specialist procurement Spencer Clark
Community safety partnership Damian
Gaylor Leander cable Stephen Butcher and
Hannah Wheatley So Right Moving On we've
done all our welcomes and thank you
apologies for absence we don't have any
Bernard do we we've got a full house not
received the Full House thank you chair
excellent minutes of the last meeting
and matters are rising
hang on I haven't said it yet councilor
fluke
um to confirm the minutes of the
performance governance and audit
committee meeting held on the 19th of
January 2023 found on pages 5 to 11. I
um cancer Edwards
Mick skins is not in attendance
oh
Gonna Cancel skeins is not in attendance
no apologies but he's not here thank you
councilor Edwards
um thank you I didn't so my apologies
Council skeins
um cancer stilts uh thank you madam just
one quick question and I said didn't
have any tonight looking at the minutes
on page a
um it said the officers will look at
events that have been discontinued and
determined if the impact on tourism
levels and report back outside of the
meeting did we actually get a report on
that outside of the meeting
um Bernard did we
is that
[Music]
all the questions around tourism was
responded to on that email sent to all
members following the meeting it's um
it's a huge amount of documents so okay
thank you
okay so do I um I propose those minutes
are agreed is that agreed by ascent
page
13 I think it is it it speaks to it
speaks to the tourism but I don't recall
seeing anything else coming back from
this committee on tourism
other than the matters arising from the
minutes
that is that is what um it's been
referred to matters arising from the
minutes
well that says that officers will look
at the events that have been
discontinued it doesn't it doesn't give
an outcome but I think that um Miss
Casey referred to another document which
I'm certainly disadvantaged because I've
not seen that so I I I you know I know
we're an email
members on the 20th of
penultimate items were around tourism
the issue about officers looking at
events that have been
and the second query on tourism was that
there was stationed through visit Essex
and when available
in the next quarter and both of those
issues were addressed on
member email issued on the 20th of
February and you would like me to bring
forward that to war members again I'm
more than happy to do so but I sent it
to you today chairman yes
thank you thank you Berna Mr Dodson do
you want to
come in I was only going to say a very
very similar thing really that the the
page 13 with the um the reference to the
matters arising it's a crib sheet to
show when it was responded to rather
than the information itself so that
members can then look that up separately
German there's a point of reference then
I think rather than just say completion
date it would be most useful if you
could say underneath that all member
email because then perhaps some of us
might have looked a little bit harder
and it would certainly direct other
members that are looking at this report
that's not on this committee
um okay point taken but I'd also like to
thank the Clark who
um yes I spoke to the clerk this
afternoon about um so I could actually
read everything again myself to be
familiar to it but I mean it is the
first time cancer fluke remembers that
we've actually started to do this and
the amount of information that has been
submitted
um what we asked to be submitted I think
needs to be commended so we'll take that
on board but I actually want to thank
Miss Casey for actually producing this
and chasing to get the relevant
information to come back in good time to
this committee so uh thank you in this
case I'd like that minute please okay
thank you okay
so members have we got any more queries
to the matters arising
I think it's quite straightforward
waiting on the information for the
Pontoon that's to follow
um that's going to come I think in a few
weeks time
um to have the timeline about the burner
on Crash pontoon but everything else
else I think is quite straightforward on
there it's a work in progress and the
clerk is actually monitoring it so can I
Bernard do I can I put them both
together or do you want the minutes
first and then matters arising agreed
[Music]
away okay so can we note then matters
arise in members and move on yeah yeah
okay thank you moving on declare thank
you Berner Declarations of interest to
disclose the existence and nature of any
disclosable pecuniary interests other
registerable interests and
non-registerable interests relating to
items of business on the agenda have a
regard to paragraph 9 and appendix B of
the code of conduct for members members
are reminded that they are also required
to disclose any such interest as soon as
they become aware should the need arise
throughout the meeting any members
moving on agenda item five public
participation Berner with do we have any
public participation
thank you so moving on to the items on
the agenda for business members internal
audit report we move to a gender item
six pan as found on pages 15 to 16 and
we're going to welcome Mr Rubens
and I think Mr Rubens is going to
present the report Mr rib is what we're
going to do after you've presented we're
going to go Page by Page the members can
raise any queries Page by page so can we
do one report at a time please
thank you okay happy to do that um there
are a lot of reports but I know
hopefully it won't take too long so um
the progress report firstly
um and I'll talk to page 19
um so just to uh set out
um there are four reports we finalized
one relating to last year which was the
last one outstanding from there and
three reports from this year they're all
in your pack
um and we have made uh one change to the
plan for this year uh which is the
workforce management review has been put
into next year because if um because the
timing doesn't work at the moment
um because of the the work that's being
done there and instead we've got a um a
review of human resource management
system has come in instead which we're
working on so um progress is on track
and for the June meeting we'll have the
remainder of the reports and all the
work will be completed and happy type
okay Quince on that members
no okay
so members um I'd like to just recommend
that report to council do I have a
secondary
agreed yep cancer stilts and then it's
been agreed
moving on to agenda item
um I've lost my place
6B thank you
um Pages 27 to 34.
um recommendation follow-up
recommendation reports
Reuben
thank you so I'll speak to page 30 on
this which is the summary
um you'll see that we have been able to
sign off to recommendations relating to
corporate governance but there are five
still outstanding including three on
flood management which as members may
remember particularly those who've been
on this committee sometime they have
been outstanding for some time so we
would like to see those closed off as
soon as possible you'll see within the
detail there are actions being taken so
it's not that the recommendations are
being ignored but you know these have
been very long-standing so I would like
to see them closed off for next time and
happy to take comments or questions
members
um councilor Stevens please
thank you chair a few questions
um if I could ask the question and get
the answer and then I'll go on to the
next one or I'll just get really lost
thank you
um there's mentioning here of something
called scrutiny training
um I've I've never been offered that I
don't know anything about scrutiny
training so I think that isn't very well
publicized maybe somebody could comment
on that please thank you
which page number
B corporate governance B
is that that the one you're referring to
page 31 yeah yeah
anybody can help Mr Dodson
just stay with us one second
it is actually on the new working
program for new members I think I think
it is uh Council fluka
you know what Miss Hughes is doing
I believe that that is the answer that
it's on the um that
um induction training and that's when
when that'll be be um introduced for
members so that there's an opportunity
for members to get that scrutiny
training
cancer Stevens I'll come to you in a
minute thank you for that
um and then on page 32 and maybe going
down onto 33 there are a lot of items
assigned to the same officer where the
date has been just crossed out and put
another one and crossed out and put
another one and I would query why aren't
we reassigning it to somebody else and
how realistic are these dates what
what's happening there how does that
keep happening thank you
let's go
Mr Dodson
thank you yes I mean clearly there's
there's an issue when that that happened
a number of times
um and it's an area that through the
review of
um Service delivery that's recently been
undertaken it's one of the things that
will be looked at as part of of that
obviously in the meantime
um the aim is to get that that resolved
as quickly as possible but it was one of
those those areas that was raised that
was a concern and that will be picked up
and potentially reassigned within that
obviously
um Mr Holmes isn't here tonight to give
the detail which I'm sure he could
around how how exactly he's he's looking
to address that and I don't know if Mrs
Green has got any any detail on that or
whether we can answer through Mr Holmes
when he's back the screen
don't have any information on that I'm
afraid members this evening
we could certainly undertake to give a
response when Mr Holmes is back yeah
next week Miss case can you take a note
of that because it's a point well made I
think it has been raised before concerns
of slippage and changing of dates and
and I think it's a very valid point can
I just go to council fluke now I'll come
back to you because it might be relevant
to the point you was making Council
Fluker well no I'll give away oh okay I
want to speak to a different point okay
we were going through page
well we've done but report by report
no no report let let's go
I don't mind all sure that we do it in
we're just going with it shall we indeed
um there's mentioned on page 33 of
people not attending safeguarding I've
prepared for this too long ago meetings
or training or something
um I'd like to know how many people
didn't attend and why please
I've certainly not got that information
to hand and it's something we can look
at if we are able to provide that was
um Mr Leslie yeah I think I recall um
from last time it was about having the
right people there and a bit of a
refresh was going on to look at the
group and make sure that we had the
right people there who could make the
biggest impact so I was actually looking
to reassign the group I think uh Mr
Geller as well spoke around that so I
don't know if there's anything to add
but I think that was around actually
having a reset of the group making sure
the right people are at the table and
again there's people who have the
biggest impact there so the group could
have a refresh and starting a new I
think I believe that was the um the idea
but uh can perhaps confirm
good evening members good evening yeah I
can't confirm um and this was raised in
the previous uh PGA meeting
um there is a review of the designated
safeguarding officers and their ability
to attend the safeguarding Forum that
hold and holds
um we're trying to make this important
size uh and give those smaller group of
offices of you know afraid to focus to
be able to attend what I would say is
that that point was was raised to be
escalated to overness for discussion so
I'm having discussions with the um
committee services for r1s to go through
that but in terms of
Officer attendance what I would
certainly say is
can sometimes be a bit live it's not
affecting I just want to give members
that reassurance because this is a very
important subject it's not affecting our
ability to respond to psychology
concerns and reports that we're
receiving it's just the internal
um General forum for discussion uh where
it's a bit like hopefully that gives
some reassurance
Council Stevens
a bit of reassurance I'll be watching it
thank you okay thank you any further
questions uh cancer fluka please see our
page 31 at the top this is the one about
here in the uh
salute area planning committees I mean
Council made the decision on the 15th of
December that this wasn't going to
happen but it's clearly not what that
says in current progress
um you know I think it's done and dusted
I think we all know what happened on the
evening
um and it was the will of the council
not to agree to dissolving the three
area planning committees so I was also
sort of expecting to see that there and
then it goes on to say additionally
overview and scrutiny commuter also has
a work plan of items
um I don't think they're connected at
all so I think that's blurring it
slightly I think that was all around
decision making progress um decision
making but the the the whole of the
weight of the past report was based
around this local Authority
um success rates at defending Appeals
and and to be honest with you it is
quite poor when compared to other local
authorities but of course the majority
of those the large majority of those
appeals that were were upheld were
actually delegated decisions so
um yeah I don't think that's really got
an awful lot to do what's going to
overview in scrutiny that was all to do
with the quality of decision making I
believe
um but then that was really only one
particular item but it depends the the
the the
gentleman from Paz
um you know he seemed to add a huge
amount of weight to the fact that we'd
lost so many appeals but when you
actually drilled into it I think 98 of
them were delegated decisions so I find
it a bit odd
okay yes please yeah and just to note
that it's a completed that that was what
I was going to say is to know these are
completed recommendations hence hence
it's a reference back to to close the
loop but I I just think it's we know
they're complete but again somebody who
reads this it it still looks open-ended
even though it's headed under complete
so it would be good I think if it just
said that it was decided by Council that
it um that it wasn't going to happen
that's fine um hang on a little bit do
you think you raised a valid point so is
do we need to add something else to the
report do we need to add anything else
to the report
um I I can do I mean actually you know
the the original finding was just that
the council needed to decide on those
issues and I think that there was a
problem that everything was all bound up
together so everything was being delayed
and we just said look if you don't want
to do certain things that's fine but get
on with the things that you do want to
do and I think that's exactly what's
happened so I don't have a problem with
with what's happened there and that's
why we've closed it if you'd like us to
refine the wording in any way happy to
do that
you know I think Mr Rubens is absolutely
right but um it's just cloudy isn't it
that it you know the idea was dismissed
the council and you know no doubt it
would come back in six months but you
know
I think it's a point well made because
then it's closed off otherwise we're
going to keep looking back we need to
actually close some of this off rather
than keep it coming back uh cats thank
you Council of Luca cancer Edwards and
then councilor Thompson
just a couple of uh observations first
of all I just want to confirm what
council fluger said I have actually been
looking at the appeals that have been
allowed since beginning of this year
they were 18 that were allowed one was
the south east committee 17 were
dedicated
um
my other question is um
lost it now
fabric management morning Council not
sorry page 32 first item modern Council
not the lead flood Authority I do know
that the environmental agency are
looking at habers as one of the main
pledge alleviation schemes to be looked
into
in this County and I just wondered if if
there's any way that the world members
could be involved in any discussions
with the environment agency and the
flood Authority thank you
um cancer Redwood yeah
yes I made a statement to council I
think pre previously that that
highlighted the the process that the
environment agency are going through and
that in in due course as they go through
their business planning process there
will be a full consultation on that and
of course the the board members will be
involved in that I just also wanted to
touch on the the planning issue and just
to highlight that it would be
um expected that the the majority of
those are delegated decisions because
the vast majority of applications that
are considered by The Authority are
delegated to decisions it's a very small
minority of um applications that do
actually come through the the member
committees
I'm surprised you're not going to come
back actually Council Road was with the
success and the failure right there but
there we go we'll leave it there um
Cassie Thompson please thank you similar
to point to Mr Dobson's actually as we
um
as something like 90 of decisions are
delegated
um you'd expect at least 90 of the
decisions of of the appeal rates to be
that kind of proportion so it wouldn't
be half an hour or anywhere near it yeah
I mean if you could let me come back
because I did but we need to see both
sides of this and I think from what
council Edwards said we don't see many
delegated decisions that have been
defended on appeal and I think this is
where we need to have that data you need
to see all three sites you know the
members involvement the officers where
they've upper where appeals have been
upheld and where appeals being dismissed
um and I I don't see an awful lot that
are upheld but it is what it
um can I ask a question of Mr Rubens
because there is normally a audit
um that comes through to this committee
about those appeals isn't there I can't
remember what month they come through
I'm sure I've seen them previously
cancer still it's when you was the chair
of this committee I'm sure we used to
have reports didn't we which which gave
as the the actual figures or that
documented figures do you not do that Mr
Rubens anymore ah well we used to
chairman if I could I I don't think it
was the audit that they came through its
performance figures and I believe they
are included in the balance scorecard
but I can check that okay that's where
that planning data should come through
okay thank you brilliant so we've got
there in the end any more questions on
6B
I will go into 6C and then we'll take
the whole of them on mass at the end to
do the uh recommendation so six see Mr
Rubens you're getting off quite lightly
really aren't you you can cut it out a
little if you want to make you worth
welcome in here no don't worry I'm happy
to get away um so uh 6C is the contract
management report so
um this was the one from last year that
was still outstanding uh it's come out
moderate Assurance on the design and
Effectiveness
um so there are some good practices in
place
um there's a policy there we were able
to find sign contracts for all of the
um suppliers that we checked
um and there were proper penalties and
break Clauses in the contracts
um the issues were really around and
particularly consistency
um so that two out of the five that we
tested there wasn't the evidence there
to see that there were regular
performance monitoring meetings
happening
um in one contract the public
convenience one there weren't any formal
key performance indicators or formal
performance monitoring Arrangements I
mean officers told us that there were
some informal meetings but obviously
we're looking for evidence of that and
then on all the contracts
um there were no evidence of risk
assessments and risk registers which
according to your contract procedure
rules should be in place for the larger
contracts so those were the main
findings but you know we've got good
management responses on those which will
follow up in due course okay
um it's white
um Debbie White
would you like to speak on that please
because they were medium assurances so
can you actually assure the committee
that you we are actually as a counselor
doing to what we should be doing to now
because I'm a little bit surprised that
those you know some of these are
long-standing contracts and when I read
them and they are highlighted in my
paperwork and I think Council um Mr
Dodson can see that I was a bit
concerned about it so can you give
assurance that we are actually now doing
what we should be doing or if not we
will be thank you
good evening
put in place to me
[Music]
to move the rules there's training
sessions
um a lot of new documents have been
created and guidance around contract
management and we will we are
implementing that as we go and as we're
putting new contracts in place
and in terms of some of the contracts
that were reviewed they're going to be
renewed shortly anyway
um so we will make sure there are
stronger kpis and one monitoring
procedures around that okay thank you Mr
Romans when would you audit that again
please would you be able to tell me in a
resurre Day committee
to make sure they are in place and
everything
so
looking at the dates some of them were
in March and I think some of them were
in May and June so we'll we should be
able to for the June meeting be able to
report back on progress thank you Berner
could you take a note of that for me
please for the committee that it could
be it'll be reported back in hopefully
June
thank you
um members any questions
um councilor Stevens
thank you chair
um this is going to sound slightly
pedantic and nerdy and but it is a
genuine question on page 38 it refers to
contracts having penalty Clauses does it
mean that they've got penalty Clauses or
should that actually say liquidated
damages because they're very different
thank you
um Miss White
did you hear what councilor Stevens said
I I didn't no not too late sorry would
you want to say it louder
yes so in a contract if you have a
penalty Clause it might say or if you
don't deliver this thing by 10 in the
morning I'll charge you a million pounds
well it might cost you a bit if they
don't deliver it by 10 in the morning
but not a million pounds
um whereas liquidated damages the
penalty for not delivering by 10 in the
morning would be directly the amount
that it costs you which might be 100
pounds and in this report it refers to
the contracts having penalty Clauses
which is quite unusual I would expect
them to have liquidated to damages
because penalty Clauses are not
enforceable in the court of law and I
just wondered which it meant please
thank you
um Mr Leslie did you want to come in are
you you know
okay thank you no miss what do you know
that that or do we need to come get a
response back from Miss Holmes or
somebody
okay well it's a good question though
thank you so we'll get that come back to
us um cancer Stevens next question
thank you um on page 47
um it talks about contracts that well
where there isn't a written contract I'd
like to know are those older contracts
that they did have a contract in writing
and have now gone beyond their end date
and nobody's finalized a renewal so
there there are some terms but we've
gone past the end date or are they new
contracts that we're actually undergoing
on a verbal basis please thank you
um are you able to confirm that sorry
well I think if you're talking about
page 47 that was the terms of reference
and it was a risk that that might not
happen but it was it it hasn't happened
in practice as I said there are
contracts in place so page 47 is just
the risks that we looked at just to make
sure that there were proper Arrangements
okay so am I hearing that all contracts
have got something in writing with a a
future end date
for the ones that we reviewed we sample
tested we didn't look at everything
okay thank you I think we can seek
reassurance though counselor I'm
dreadful for ma Stevens
um I think we can ask Mr
um
homes when he comes back can't we
um surely it's his director isn't it
well con contracts
chairman cover a lot of the the council
so I think with this audit I just want
to point out is that uh we've asked the
internal Auditors to review these
contracts because we feel that they are
significant the authority and we wanted
to make sure that they were robust and
we quite rightly expected
recommendations to come through to help
us improve against these contracts so
that's the reason we've we've chosen
these ones because of the significance
to to the authority I want to make sure
that they were being managed as best as
possible obviously the council has a
whole range of contracts it has a
contract register which it publishes um
as well and managers and centrally
um the procurement team will monitor
those to check for renewals um start
date end dates and check that there are
contracts in place now part of that work
is to go through
um spend as well and pick up from
procurement side of it and actually
check that these things are in place and
if they do find areas where they're a
spend without contracts in place that's
when we will put action to address that
and get those contracts put in place and
that's part of the monitoring and check
in within the systems and I don't know
if Miss White has anything more to add
as well the the quality control if you
like that's right
um
is in place and we will keep continually
reviewing that okay thank you I think
Council Stevens is right to raise it
though because obviously we've only had
a sample raised and there are areas that
have been highlighted so it would be
nice I I think and beneficial to the
council that at some stage we do get an
updated report whether it be three
months or or six months I don't think
that's unreasonable request
um cancer Stevens and then cancer stilts
thank you for that yes just to put it in
context I mean if if any contract
manager in the whole country has got a
list of say 100 contracts and every
single one of them has got an end date
in the future wow I'd be incredibly
impressed there's normally some contract
that you just you've gone past the end
date because stuff went wrong and that's
fine if it's one or two I'm just trying
to gauge whether it's one or two and
somebody's on it or it's half the
contracts and nobody's looking at it
it's that's you know that level of
assurance that I'm looking for please
don't get something back don't worry
are on it
well said
well done thank you for the reassurance
cancer stilts please thank you page 41
um and it's Mr rubin's report he says
without significance performance
arrangements and easily measurable
targets the council is at risk of not
adequately monitoring contact
contractors and identifying potential
issues within Service delivery in a
timely manner have we actually tightened
that up as well
who's answering that one Mr Rubens Mr
Leslie
Miss white again is it you you're in the
hot seat I'm so sorry
um and working with contractors that we
engage with
um absolutely yes does that reassure
your cancer Stills another question yeah
we'll come up there's another question
but it's not on this part
um and that is do we actually specially
with the ones that do our um
public conveniences do we make sure that
we have got safeguarding on those
I would hope so
thank you at the moment and and we are
putting in place the necessary
um safeguards and checks so yes
um I'm working with Damian on that as
well just to make sure that that's all
included in future contracts as well
yeah that's quite it's quite important I
think that's that's one of the areas
that you know it needs to be really um
looked at and done as a matter of
priority I would have thought Mr Leslie
did you you're trying I can't see you
over there sorry I was just going to
pick up that's part of the review
because that was part of the audit that
gave in the audit recommendations in
terms of the safeguarding so that's the
sort of activity that that's been picked
up so when when that spoken about yes
that's part of the following up of
recommendations as well around that area
okay any more questions members should
we move on to 6D
um the interlude report safeguarding
right Mr Rubens
okay so this one not so positive
um we've given a limited Assurance on
the design of the controls on this one
moderate on the effectiveness although
um there are some weaknesses
um we did actually note we did note some
positives though some improvements since
the last time we reviewed this area so
in particular there's a new case
management system because we had an
issue last when we last audited around
lack of documentation lack of an audit
Trail not being able to see what
happened with cases well that is all now
dealt with through this new system and
it seems to be working well and we
tested five
um safeguarding concerns and saw that
they've been dealt with appropriately so
that's very positive in terms of the
areas for improvement there's one in
particular which we've rated as a high
priority which is around the use of
volunteers and making sure there's a
comprehensive list of volunteers and
their safeguarding any safeguarding
issues around that including whether
they're coming into contact with
children vulnerable people so that's a
particular priority to be able to deal
with that one but there were some other
issues that we've picked up including
the need to be more consistent around
contracts so that was just mentioned
previously
um in fact again there is an improvement
here because last time we looked at it
the contractual Arrangements haven't
really been looked at at all in terms of
safeguarding now we've noticed there are
some but it's not comprehensive so that
needs to be put in place
um there was the issue around attendance
at meetings which one of the members
picked up before
um and then finally around the
safeguarding policy making sure that's
up to date and has got relevant officers
named in it so a number of areas there
again we've got a good action plan uh to
address that and we'll be following that
up in due course
thank you well some improvement but
would miss white or Mr Gala like to
speak on anything just to reassure meant
that yeah Mr Gala thank you
thank you just to try not to remember
some reassurance so I cannot reassurance
that we have begun to work on that uh
volunteers list so the volunteers list
is currently under the ownership of the
Strategic Community lead and and
basically they're going to list out the
volunteers that we're we use that we
engage with
um I will then follow that up with some
various verification checks uh the same
can be sort of contractors list uh we're
working through active contractors and
again I'll begin a verification process
and essentially check with either
volunteers or as to whether
they do on I'll check it make sure it's
a purpose that'd be fine if we feel that
the safeguarding process either either
isn't there or is it satisfactory I will
then be recommending the things that are
sign up to ours and there's a
as well so this is stuff that's ready to
go
in terms of the safeguarding meetings
obviously that that's been broken it's
already
in terms of the policy yes there is a a
program I want to follow to begin the
refresh process for that and that will
take place over 23 24. I do need to
agree a day where I'll finally deliver
that document so I'll be working towards
that one thing I would say is we're
really trying to use the you know the
audit processes to highlight where some
of the gaps are and so basically get
straight in there and try and correct
those areas
again just to remind members that we
have
um there's some this I've got the
process to speak to ons as well just to
reassure that there are checking
balances lots of checks and balances in
place for um for the safe colleague work
so hopefully that gives some ratio
um I think it gives slums to Gayla but
have we got a more precise timeline
because this has been around a long time
and um safeguarding is a serious serious
issue and it's getting more serious
day-to-day at all canceled at all levels
so um have you got any dates or any
timeline that can be you know uh three
months six months you know your
volunteers whatever can you reassure us
um finalize that to have the list up
running by the end of April um the same
for the contractors list
um in terms of the meetings the
designated safeguarding officers I'm due
to set new meetings for the coming
Financial year for the safeguarding
Forum and in that Quorum the next
meeting we will be discussing
the designated safeguarding offices that
we think will be super
um for the uh for the for the meetings
um in terms of the policy that's that's
a bit longer so I'm I'm honest I would
expect delivery for that towards the end
of the financial year
okay what about your list you didn't
give me a date for the list you gave me
the first two and the last two I didn't
get a date
first meeting for the First new list
probably the
well the reason why I'm referring to the
safeguarding meeting
so I would say okay we'll be in the
first quarter of the financial year okay
so yeah thank you
then and then
the last one you said the end quarter
okay thank you so forgive me Members
because I asked a few questions before
opening it out to you so I apologize
members anybody got any questions
uh cancer stilts
uh thank you madam chair I must admit
safeguarding is a worry because as Mr
Rubens brings this to our attention if
there was a safeguarding issue we would
just be as fault as anyone else
um what does worry me and I think it's
Paige
52 is where it says that while some
departments within the council have
contractor arrangements to ensure
safeguarding procedures in place the
procedure team intend to include this in
future tenders what does all partner can
all apartments see though that list so
if I was working in one department and I
wanted to check on a contractor is that
easily done does our system talk to each
other
what's that the main list is completed
it will include both volunteers and
contractors it's a very comprehensive
list it has a series of questions so one
of them will be oh are they using their
own safeguarding policy are they not
when's the next time I'm do check with
them so once that new list is completed
it will be centralized it's in the
procurement folder in on a SharePoint uh
folder that everyone can access
um if members want to see it
um as far as I'm concerned there's no
personal details on there it should be
something that nobody's can scrutinize
at any point I think we just really
wanted the reassurance it was there
thank you is that right cancer stilts
yeah okay any more questions members
um officers anybody want to stay nope
move on sex let's take six six e sorry
somewhere else uh six e um Mr Reuben
so this is the um audit of uh strategic
performance in the place uh directorate
uh it's come out and put very positively
uh as a substantial Assurance on the
design and moderate on the effectiveness
um a lot of good practice there we
thought um very clear objectives clear
strategy clear performance indicators
good monitoring good reporting so you
know lots of good practice there we
think um so really good to see the um
the main issue we found which might be
of interest to members was really around
um the the PGA meetings and the extent
to which
um councilors requests and queries are
followed through on and also you know
showing clearly where performance is
behind track that that has been actioned
and been addressed so
um I I you know I understand you know
work's already underway I saw that
obviously the matters are rising seem to
be better
um but um you know we've got an action
in place to address that
um by June and obviously again we'll
follow that up next time excellent
members we've got a tick in our boxes
we're doing something right cancer fluka
yeah thank you chairman yeah I did pick
up on that piece I paid for the areas
that can
know I'm really pleased Mr Rubens that
you've highlighted this and
um and it's a shame really because this
is a bit of a problem that goes right
the way through the committee structure
where we don't do follow-ups so you know
I'm delighted actually that committee
services are picked up on this and
they're doing what they're doing because
I think that's going to provide good
tracking for the future thank you
totally agree and thank you members for
allowing us to introduce it we we
started that here
well I'm not chairman of those
committees but I'm sure if you are next
time you'll be able to bring It Forward
[Laughter]
no that thank you and thank you for
recognizing it it's nice the officers
work very very hard they well they often
do but uh yeah thank you
um six F members Community safety
oh oh sorry oh I do apologize cancer
Stills is a question thank you and
um on page 63 you say in order to
achieve this for the place um strategy
now it's the six key areas you've got
Club resilience and air quality
pollution but we've already seen in your
report that those are two areas that are
a problem
will that depend on those two areas then
come in on board
um well it's all part I think of of the
structure that we're talking about so
those two need to be obviously as I said
included along with everything else to
make sure you can see the improvements
happening and the action happening so
you know that's what we want to want to
see in place I think it's a good
question but it's down to this committee
to make sure we monitor it and that
things are and then hopefully we'll have
the officers either in hopefully in the
chamber on stage and they can actually
explain to members why or what issues
and problems they've had which doesn't
bring it to
of fruition as I call it but a good
question anybody else nope moving on six
six F Community safety I'm sure we've
just done that
Community safety again very positive
report substantial on design moderate on
Effectiveness a lot of good practice
again you've got your community safety
plan in place good risk assessments
um and we can see
um uh good public engagement as well as
part of that so
um the the main issue that we've raised
in terms of an improvement uh is again
around
um having full representation at the
relevant group The responsible Authority
group
um and it where people aren't attending
and they're supposed to be providing
updates it just meant the update wasn't
given at all so you know it's important
to make sure that those the the right
people attend or if they don't attend
they delegated to someone else who can
provide that update so that again has
been accepted and again we'll follow up
in due course
um
um yeah thank you Mr councilor fluka
yeah so just a point of clarity there Mr
Rubens on page 76 areas of concern are
you are you referring to members of the
group or members of the council
um so pay 76 there is concerned sort of
third line down second sentence
so so the the actual um representatives
are on page 77 and listed there so you
have the chief executive there's also
representation from the police the
clinical commissioning group and so on
so those are the people that we're
talking about in terms of the attendance
so if I'm just so it does actually
that's why I asked because it it it did
say that you can you can add four
members but I'm still not sure if that
if there are any members elected members
on this group but I mean that's
you know that is quite an appalling
indictment and and bear in mind is group
thank you no chairman I never saw your
lips man okay
um thank you yeah well but we've got to
be careful because I'm not sure if it
means the actual members of that group
of which there are a lot
um and come from various agencies but I
mean that's quite a bad indictment
really isn't it and I you know I don't
know
um Mr Rubens if you know this your
report has gone back to uh all of these
people
um your findings
come on
that's the name of this of those groups
who's referring to I think it's doing Mr
Rubens yeah okay I'm just I just like
that how can we make sure it happens
because there's no point in US auditing
something we've got no control over if
we're failing
um
go to Mr Rubens then Spencer well
Spencer might be better
where we see it's disappeared
Spencer Clark oh hello
thank you
um
Council point of view because modern
District's always been attendance at the
meetings and serve our elected members
you'll see on page 76 which goes on to
77. they audited the last three rag
meetings and at one of the meetings that
provides there was no probation update
um and and as I explained to the auditor
there's generally some very good reasons
but they're not being updates or
attendance at those meetings I know
probation we're going through quite a
difficult patch in terms of a major
review at the time of their attendance
and likewise with the police
where they had attendance it's been
because of operational reasons but still
it doesn't mean there hasn't been at all
police update because we always give the
performance update for Essex police and
our report on their behalf if they don't
attend so as you quite widely say it is
is a little bit about our van power but
they are all secretary members under the
prime disorder act 1998 so they should
all attend and I I really you know I
like this recommendation that and that
if for some reason they can't attend but
they shouldn't send Identity or send a
written written three for nothing in
advance because I think it's only right
so
um so I welcome the recommendation and
what what the plan is is once we've
reviewed this report tonight and it's
published is that the next response
authorities boot meeting which is two
weeks to die we'll go through this
report and and you know and all of the
members all the strategy members of that
group we have an opportunity to comment
on it you know and I think it will give
quite a lot of weight for future
attendance and you know and future
reports going forward so I welcome the
recommendation thank you and I reckon
welcome your comments actually it was
very honest and I'm sure miss Casey will
take notes and come back to this
committee following the the meeting in
two weeks time that can report to us
councilor Fleming
thank you chair evening Spencer I just
wanted to ask is it sort of uh the sort
of notice period that is given is that
you know are they sort of set quarterly
or you know is that the issue or maybe
the time of day that the meeting is held
the major league the meetings are set
called quarterly and they're all really
in place for the Hubble this year up
until March 2024 so all of those
meetings are already in the diary
so I think you know so everyone has
plenty of opportunity in advance to know
that the meetings are there likewise
plenty of opportunity to send the deputy
or even a short-written briefing though
yeah I mean but you know generally I
think you'll see that the attendance be
quite good I mean the last one would be
few years is eight out of eight people
with the attendees who should have been
there so yeah so it's been it's always
been ready for acceptance so it's been
75 of those statutory members they're
all means
just your standards are too high Mr Ruby
thank you any any further questions
remember uh councilor Thompson and then
cancer Stevens please
um thank you and forgive me for not
knowing this but does council actually a
point as a substitutional deputy for the
elected member and perhaps we should in
in the event that councilor who I think
it's a very good point so I think it's a
recommendation then there's something
ought to be in place shouldn't it yeah
um it's Casey Could you actually make a
note of that to see if we could actually
change that at statutory annual can we
please so we can make a recommendation
that it is um reviewed Mr yes chairman
we can certainly look into that into I
can't I can't remember
um if there is a substitute but but also
to to emphasize I do believe councilor
hubner has been present at all of the
meetings today while he's been the
representative brilliant thank you
Council Stevens then cancel fluka
thank you chair on page 80 there's a
mention of a web page that hadn't been
updated and was referring to the
previous year
um I suppose that sort of put me on the
alert because within about 10 minutes of
reading this I found two other web pages
in the same situation I've raised fresh
service tickets for those
um but I think as we now come into the
new Financial year could we have a bit
of an effort to go
through all the web pages and make sure
that they are referring to the right
year because I think quite a few of them
may not be thank you thank you Mr Dodson
thank you chairman yes it is an issue
that's been picked up and a officer
working groups being established to to
look at both the the latest information
on the website and also to look at how
we embed that responsibility across the
board to make sure that those are
updated in the future as well thank you
Council fluka well Tim I was just going
to
um through you to my friend the
community safety manager Spencer Clark
um it's um it might might be the time
maybe for this group to look at their
own Constitution to allow for
substitutes and and then that can you
know that can filter down to the members
that are involved throughout the the
county I think that makes sense actually
but I think it's
you know it's quite an interesting one I
presume they'll invite Mr Rubens along
to account for himself
he's more than welcome okay any more
questions members not we'll move on to 6
G
Okay so
Mr Reuben right final one on the final
uh final run so this is the plan for
next year
um it's as usual it's been discussed and
agreed with officers uh it's uh reflects
your risk register and the key risks
that the council has
um and um it will be flexible as always
so you know during the year if new risks
come along where we'll be able to
accommodate for that
um there's normal ones you'd expect to
see but I think some interesting ones
there around for example equality
diversity inclusion climate change uh
sickness absence
um we as always we'll do some work
around fraud as well
um and something around section 106 uh
spends and management as well so I think
a good range of of topics and audits
there but as always happy to take on
board any um comments from members
okay well I'd like to page 88 it says
future focused Assurance I was actually
pleased and I put good we've been trying
I think since um who was the really nice
counselor who was the uh Vice chair of
this committee who resigned Carl Jarvis
when we was we was on this committee
right at the very beginning of this
Administration
um we actually said about trying to do
something proactively rather than
reactively and looking at that that
looks as though that's what you're
actually trying to do so I'd like to
congratulate you on that
um I'm going to shut up and let members
speak because I've got a few questions I
want to raise but I'd like the members
to speak before me so members have you
got any questions Council Stevens
thank you chair um risk 33 lack of
temporary accommodation and social
housing to cope with demand
um it's a for like likelihood of four
and an impact of four I would say this
isn't really a risk it's an issue so I'm
quite surprised to see it in the bottom
right hand corner and I just wonder if
somebody could explain that more to me
please thank you very much
Mr Leslie
yeah so um what the report draws on is
uh risks from our risk register in order
to inform it so that's what it's pulled
on so the report isn't about our risk
register obviously we have different
ones about that side of it um but indeed
what it looks at is the consequence
um of that as we go through the risk
register how the things appear so look
at the consequence of it with the impact
of it happening what are the likelihood
of it happening and obviously we know
that there's increased pressures around
homelessness because of the the reasons
at the moment and therefore the
likelihood is higher and obviously the
consequence to
um the community and the individuals as
well as the council is on there so
that's how the risks have been put on
the risk register
um for that side
um
yeah cancel this um Stevens again please
thank you I'm not entirely sure I
understand that so if we've got a family
who's had to be housed in Peterborough
because there wasn't any accommodation
here which we have
um well that is a lack of temporary
accommodation and social housing to cope
with demand
um and it's not that's not an isolated
case I'm going to go into Peterborough
is but constantly I'm on the Strategic
housing board and every time I get a
list of what's available for people this
this week to look at through the Gateway
for Home Choice there's almost nothing
it's really maybe five properties in the
whole District that and once or twice
there were no properties in the whole
District it doesn't seem to me to be a
low risk
there's no excuse me it's it's shown as
a high risk
it's a four not a five and it's showing
a likelihood of four but actually it's
happening so it's not just nearly there
it's it's right up there and an impact
of four well if you're suddenly being
shipped off to Peterborough that's not
an impact of four
um the
I've not got the got the the detailing
in front of me but a four out of four is
a very high corporate risk uh a level
five would be
um
potential
um failure of the council
corporately so so four is a very high
operational risks risk Mr Leslie might
be able to to add something to that but
that that you know they are really high
corporate risks in terms of how that's
presented there that's a Fleming please
just going to point out that this is the
plan going forward it's it's not the
actual risk register
um cancer still Council fluka please
thank you page 91
um R4 and r10 failure to influence
Community safety we've got nothing by
that for 23 24 or 23 26. are we not
going to be looking at those until after
26 or
um well we weren't because we've
literally just done an audio as as
you've seen today we've presented it and
and you know it came out well so we
didn't see it as a particular priority
obviously if members do think it's a
priority then we should look at it again
we can put it within the Strategic plan
I don't think we'd be looking to do it
next year because we've just done one
but we could look at doing it in two or
three years time
cancer stilts again yeah of course yeah
just to come back on that I mean you've
got also the failure to to develop jobs
to support the grand population I'd like
to see them come back because they
change and although they're brilliant at
the moment in two years time we could
have a problem so I'd like to see that
we're at least keeping an eye on them
so Leslie do you want to say anything no
yes
um yeah so obviously the forward plans
down there and of course the
recommendations that are raising the
report will come up as a follow-up
report um in the next year so that's how
they keep keep track of and then the
three-year forward plan obviously on
page or starting on page 97
um it shows the allocation of the
resources to individual areas around
that
I think cancer stilts we can bring
things throughout the this this
committee at any any time if we want to
reassess it and move things around
because I've got some concerns uh later
and I had a word with the directors and
we can actually bring them forward if we
need to so it's worth noting um in this
case can you note what cancer stilts has
just said because you know it may be
okay for like like what um Mr Rubin says
it's just been done it may be okay for
six months or a year it may come back
but at least then we're going to have
that hopefully some flexibility in in
the system
um thank you very much um can I still to
be finished should I go to council with
Luca Council fluka please yeah thank you
um yes I agree what Mr Dodson said
because I think if you if you don't
manage to
hell's a homeless person that becomes
more likely to be a five but the fact
that we're managing to find some weapons
go albeit and Peterborough which isn't
satisfactory but we're actually
discharging our statutory duty to find
somewhere and we know how hard it is I
think the problem is when accommodation
in Peterborough and Maven Stone all
dries up
um but there's one overarching thing
which I I'd like to commit to Mr Rubens
consider and and and that's timelines
you know it's it's delivering projects
on time you know we've got corporate
projects which have been you know
rolling around for sort of six seven
years okay I know we've had covert in
between but you know we've soon got up
and running on teams and you know a lot
of other councils achieved quite a lot
during lockdowns
um but I think corporate time I think
timelines are very very very important
and I think I think
quickly going to a stage now where I
think that all projects all large
projects in this this Council should
have challenging timelines agreed by the
people that are involved so that we can
monitor them and move them forward I
mean most of those projects most of
those projects are considered in private
and confidential anyway but it I think
it's a it's a good way of measuring
performance and deliverability and and
it does keep the members focused as well
so it's certainly something that I'll be
asking Council to consider soon but I
think it's maybe something in the
overarching audit that you should
consider within this of of delivering
projects on time and providing
challenging
um timelines thank you
and within the Strategic plan we've got
an audit for 24.25 on Capital and
Commercial project management so that
would look at precisely that point about
our proper timeline set how they
monitored how they delivered I mean it
may be because if this is a particular
interest we can bring that slightly
forward and maybe do in quarter one of
24 25 and do it slightly earlier
um but certainly happy to you know take
that one on board I think Jeremy for
letting me come back I think Mr Edmonds
if if you
um by virtuous section 100a of the ACT
um your disadvantaged but you know we do
have a lot of very very big corporate
projects
um in the background you know and we
really need to get focused on those and
you know I would like to think that come
24 25 some of them will be dealt with
but as I said some have been dragging on
now for sort of six seven years so you
know I know you've only got a certain
amount of capacity within the audit but
I do think that
something that we should consider making
sure that we've got challenging
timelines to bring forward these
projects thank you
well I'm happy to pick up Mr Leslie
outside this meeting we can talk about
the Audits and whether it is worthwhile
shuffling things around or and bringing
that one forward thank you because
that's actually on my my list here
that's been highlighted so thank you
councilor fluka
um I think it does need to come forward
if it is going to be in 24 25 that's
fair enough but quarter one definitely
um some of these projects they need to
come to fruition or as far as I'm
concerned they need to be scrapped and
you're looking at the ones that are
going to come forward you cut sorry it
might be a bit bold but that's the
decisions you have to take when you've
got Financial
um difficulties and challenges within a
council
um anybody else cancer Stevens please
thank you chair so I'm trying to take on
board what you said about the um
homelessness and lack of housing as
being in in the scheme of things
corporately of four or whatever so okay
um so now I'm looking down at risk 11
failure to protect personal commercially
sensitive data given that I think some
of the fines are practical they might be
unlimited that would be quite a big
corporate impact if we were to get stung
by that and I'm just trying to
understand how some things end up being
a four or a three or a five and maybe
I'm just not understanding the criteria
there thank you
that that is similarly a level four risk
in terms of I believe that the
consequence
it's the likelihood that is lower so in
terms of the risk the mitigations that
have been put in place of of put that uh
that it's less likely to happen but it's
still risk 11 I believe uh impact 4
recognizing the scale of impact if that
actually did happen but also recognizing
the measures that are in place to
prevent it hence the likelihood is a
three
cancer students um Mr Leslie is going to
hopefully assist
um with um with you go on yeah sorry
it's probably not assisting but I I
think that this report is really about
the internal audit plan
um the internal return is based on the
risk register so what the report shows
is the risk registers stand and that is
the risk register obviously we do bring
the risk register to the committee for
debate but this isn't the item that it's
on so what and will we bring It Forward
we then had the debate about whether we
agree with the risk register so there is
an opportunity to debate that but this
isn't that report
um but that that's just well I'll say
but of course there is an opportunity to
to go into this discussion when we look
at the risk register itself but you're
more than welcome to raise anything you
want at this committee don't anyway
carry on okay so thank you point taken I
think really what I'm saying is that
given that the fines are unlimited if we
had a billion pound fine it would wipe
us out I think corporately that's quite
an impact that's what I'm saying thank
you okay
um cancer stilts please
thank you page 95 management of s106
funds we've got it down to be reported
on quarter four does it have to be
reported quarter four can it be reported
more often or brought back another time
I think it's a really good point because
we are constantly talking about section
106 and the failure for it to be
delivered so could it be more frequent
uh I don't know about more frequent but
I mean again we can talk to again I can
have a word with Mr Leslie about the
timing of that particular audit and
again can we do it earlier rather than
later I'm always happy to take on board
those sort of comments I think it's a
very good point thank you
um cancer fluka please I think this you
know because some of the projects I
believe are being funded out of the 106
fund and I think that's why it's
important to to have timelines
particularly the local development plan
review
um so uh yeah I see that's quite quite
an important risk although with fairness
I think we are actually doing a lot now
to to make sure we know where the money
is and what we're spending it on and
what we can spend it on yeah and and I
look forward to seeing the Galleon
installed in the park instead of some
proper housing for homeless
okay so I've got members says everybody
finished uh because I've got a few
points um hopefully um cancer Stevens
I'm going to most probably be in the
same boat as you and shouldn't be
raising them but I'm going to because
it's our committee
um the the issues I've got and I don't
know how it um
connects with the new corporate plan I
spoke briefly to Mr Dodson and he said
it's got to be you Mr Leslie I think
that's going to help me on this one is
how is the digital connectivity
um going to be brought in as a internal
audit just strategic plan where can it
be included because would that come
under like the section 106 is because if
we're going to bring and raise our
economy and our business and we've got
the fourth lowest internet speed I can't
see anything on here
um on our strategic plan for the next so
many years to 2026 how that's going to
be incorporated so we can actually move
that forward so if you can advise me in
the com the committee if they're
interested how that would come in
you've got it where
you can share your findings
sorry Joe we're just discussion what
findings we've got
um yeah I think it's something we could
look to incorporate in terms of our uh
so I.T governance I think when we say
yeah
management no yeah well I was thinking
about although that was a discussion
we're having oh geassic management or
I.T governments but possibly I.T Asset
Management might be a place but we could
certainly find a place to uh perhaps
consider that a bit more uh when we come
to the terms of reference I appreciate
that in 24
25. uh the it asset management but miss
Casey can you make a note of that though
that it is actually included though
please it is picked up
yes German thank you and I'm just
thinking cheers sorry perhaps um
we could pick that up in the plan
um with an actual note it says in the in
the comments about the digital side of
it so that we can come back to committee
to show that we've updated them that's
partly when it comes back usually
working isn't it so you we there's no
point in if we can't connect it doesn't
matter what we want to do but if you
can't connect there's nothing you can do
next one members if you'll just allow me
um I've just sort of put taken into the
resource constraints in our new
corporate plan I I think we need tighter
controls with our budget and Performance
Management but it seems to have been
taken off this this list or I think it
was finished was it in um 23 22 23 but I
I don't think that we've got enough
um in our plan here that is going to
address or help us audit the problems
that we are most probably going to
experience in the future like any
council is is our finances so where is
that going to be picked up here and is
it going to be reported on a regular
basis I know you're going to say cancer
stamp you've got the midterm Financial
strategy and everything coming in but
where is it included in here please
so the audit plan has Main Financial
systems I think in page 93.
um
I like to write things down thank you
yep at the top and then the comments
within there talk about budgetary
control and that side so the Main
Financial systems is a annual audit so
it looks at the core Financial systems
around that so will that be detailed
enough to come to this Council about our
financial
um where we are at the time I just want
us to keep more of an eye on it because
this year we've obviously got using our
reserves and the next year is if we
don't do anything we're going to go more
and use in our Reserve so I think it's
important it either comes and gets audio
stood at this committee or it goes
somewhere that the council is well aware
what's happening with our finances yep
so um the internal audit will focus on
that sort of budgetary control of the
Main Financial systems and the sort of
the robustness and controls in place
there and then in terms of the budget
monitoring reports that come through
they go to SNR committee oh okay all
right so I'm on the wrong committee
there but as long as it is going to be
picked up somewhere I think it's it's
vital thank you for that
um and I think that's I think that's all
members has anybody else got any
follow-up to do on on anything
no okay thank you Mr Reuben
you got off quite lightly
okay members just bear with me till I
get my papers in order so
so
um
where was it
thank you
oh bear with me Members I've got to read
it read it out
I've lost my bit of paper so the
recommendations are members little one
that the terms of reference for the
performance governor and audit commit
working group oh no no no no that's the
next item agenda sorry sorry members can
we agree on block agenda item six sorry
all agreed and I'd like to thank you all
for your participation it was it was a
very very good session so now number
seven thank you
whatever I'm moving on agenda item seven
members so we don't get distracted
um the purpose of this report is to
establish a working group of the
committee for detailed review work the
recommendations are that the terms of
reference for the performance governance
and audit committee working group are
approved at appendix a and little two
that members are 0.5 committee members
to sit on the working group for the
remainder of the municipal year uh um
cancerous keys I perhaps it's me but why
are we discussing this we're at the most
there will possibly be one meeting
because none of us know we're going to
be here or even I may be sitting amongst
people and not even well no certainly
one person it's not standing yeah yeah
um
it just seems ridiculous
um the question was raised uh and about
the uh but we may need that meeting and
we do need that meeting so
sorry so so I'm afraid we are going to
form the group because we are we do need
to meet
no it was it was questioned I totally
agree but we are we will be meeting a
working group can meet very quickly and
it's going to meet very quickly cancer
still you're not going to propose from
you from there are you now I was
actually going to say that we were
trying to set up a working group for for
many years so you know I recommend that
we go forward good okay so let's move on
then so I'd like to recommend
um from the chair
um myself
counselor Fleming councilor fluka
councilor stilts how many is that four
and one more
who else would like to be on it
councilor Stevens
that was an adult chats it was cancer
Thompson
sorry sorry chairman I was certainly not
elbowing anyone out of the way but I'm
willing to I'm willing to do it so
that's agreed members
um made a note yes yep okay so thank you
moving on gender item number eight
is
the purpose of the report to consider a
request from North Banbridge Paris
Council Parish Council for a review of
The Electoral Arrangements in terms of
the size of its membership the
recommendation members that the request
of North fanbridge Parish Council to
instigate a community governance review
to be agreed I propose from the chair
do I have a second there
um okay well I'll wait for the second
Council flemen's second cancel fluka
please
chairman I mean I mean if this has a
sport but if the parish council which I
guess it does I mean it's it's quite
extraordinary really because
um ashram and denge is quite a strange
Parish Council because it's a combined
Parish Council and I think collectively
I think they've probably even with all
of the development in ashwoodem
um I think there's still only 230 houses
and they've got five members so uh and I
just happen to be in North Cambridge the
other day and I was absolutely staggered
what North families looks like now so uh
you know my view is German if they think
they can fill these places we should
support them
um I would just ask Mr Leslie one
question he says that the the costs are
minimal
um it would be nice to know what minimal
means and also chairman with all the
development that's coming forward
perhaps you know we should scope some of
the other areas for example I know we've
we've we've split the parish council in
in haybridge haven't we but with some of
the other areas you know
whether or not it's likely that we're
going to be asked the same questions but
I certainly don't have any any uh
problem with this and I wish them every
success in filling the places on a
long-term basis
cancer case and I'm going to go to Mr
Dodson uh yeah how many is on it now I
can't seem to see it
we will go to Mr Dodson first and then
we'll come back yeah I did read the
report oh you're okay
yes fart is five and and five is the the
statutory minimum so they look they're
looking to increase it
um by two yeah yeah
um in terms of the the cost this would
be officer time
um and it
it's it's not something that we we
wouldn't need to do a parish referendum
or anything like that it's it's a matter
of doing a report Consulting and then
bringing it back through Council and
working with the parish council
many years myself why have they only
ever had five why was it never because
I'll sit on great Tottenham and we've
got so we've got about 12 I think 11.
wow yes we have
it is and I just wonder why fanbridge I
know we've got a heck of a lot of
building just taking place in Great
Southern but there's always been
lies in my antecedents and and I can
move my antecedents
what's gone on in the past all right
and I think that North fanbridge has
just grown exponentially I mean it's
it's no problem
I think you know 20 years ago it was a
tiny little village and it certainly has
grown and the other thing is lots of
houses have sort of disappeared they're
plotlands now you've got big houses more
people and everything else I I certainly
don't think it's an unreasonable I don't
I think Council fluke could cancel the
keys wasn't suggesting that he was just
just yeah okay yeah
no no don't ever members members if
you're going to do that you can take us
all
um Mr dougson do you want to say any
more or no I think I think um councilor
fluke largely covered covered those
reasons it's a growing Village and um
they want to broaden it yeah yeah okay
okay do we agree by sent members okay
right before we all get bored because I
can feel everybody getting restless I
think this is our last meeting isn't it
I checked the calendar and I can't see
that we're meeting again until obviously
the new Administration so I would like
to take this opportunity of thanking
everyone on this Committee in this room
I think it's been an excellent year I've
really enjoyed uh and been honored that
I've been allowed to share it I think
you've all behaved impeccably and I
think you've all been very fair and
scrutinized very well so I'd like to
thank you all and the officers and
directors for assisting me while I've
been in this chair so
and oh obviously yeah and everybody
everybody else okay so so thank you for
that and moving on to the last bit any
other items of business the chairman
decides is urgent there is none so I
close this meeting at I can't see it
properly
8 52 852 thank you safe journey home
members and we'll see you the next time
well done